what up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it is the great area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman you you
currently pissing off the manosphere
right
right thank you Sarah
right
listen
today we have a good show for you we are
talking about loneliness
or lonely
but before we even get to that Calum
if you have watched two or more of our
videos and you have not subscribed
then we have what now what we got B
exactly so you better do
you do right now
okay guys so
today
um we have we actually have a sponsor
today so a major airline has privacy
rights activists disappointed after a
recent data breach turned out to be a
gold mine for hackers the affected
customers and employees of the airline
had their social social security numbers
with drivers license numbers and other
personally identifiable information
stolen in a matter of days several other
airlines in recent years have had
similar data breaches making me wonder
if my data has ever been stolen as well
that is why I signed up with virtual
Shield one virtual Shield one's identity
protection feature scans 700 billion
data elements for suspicious activity a
Southern person personal personally
identifiable information to alert you
after a data breach it comes with an
unlimited VPN access and advanced VPN
malware and ad block in try virtual
Shield one risk for risk-free for 30
days by clicking the link in the
description box below after entering
your details you'll have instantaneous
access
Security benefits of virtual Shield one
offers
I didn't even know
um you know yeah so anyways a couple
other announcements before we get the
show started the first being that we
have two clips channels just pearly
clips and pearl daily I think we're
almost to like 200k on one of the clips
channels um I have to look
so guys if you want to be a part of the
stream today make sure you sign up for
our memberships
um our second membership our first
membership gets you to be a part of the
chat second membership you get to be a
part of our Discord and you get our
behind the scenes Vlogs third tier you
get to connect with us on social media
and fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month a lot of
people have asked about social media
coaching and if you want to do that make
sure you go to our memberships and sign
up for our fourth tier um honestly I've
helped the people get to ten thousand
twenty thousand thirty thousand
subscribers with just a couple tips so I
really recommend signing up for that
um on top of that guys I think we just
hit 600k
.com
[Music]
so thank you guys for all the new
subscribers over the weekend
um follow my Instagram just.carly things
you have to type out the whole thing
because I am Shadow band on Instagram
right now
so go to my Instagram and type that in
and also um they took away my fourth
Tick Tock now so
I've been banned one two three four
times on Tick Tock which is so rude
so rude apparently right now as I'm
reading the chat we've got audio issues
people are saying that there's no volume
oh there's no volume
um
I think they might be controlling
yeah yeah sometimes they do that why I
don't know I don't know it's such a
messed up thing to do people are
thinking that oh [ __ ] it's the same guy
he's just not that reason
yeah anyways but um yeah they took away
my first Tick Tock a second Tick Tock
third
listen they but the thing is they can't
get ready though
go follow it and just curly things
I don't know if there's a DOT or not but
I haven't just probably think of six
account but I
will whatever account you guys just
gonna piss people off yeah I'll be back
I'll be back
we do have some special guests about
Savannah
yes we do yeah as people can see
um are you finished well yeah I'm done
all right cool cool
um we have
some guests with us today special ones
we've flown in all the way from America
world one at least and if we could just
go around
introduce yourself
starting over there with you Brendan the
blue suit
my name is Troy Francis I'm arguably the
UK's greatest dating coach arguably oh
you coached me today I did like coach
pearls he coaches he coaches women too
now yes yes
a new average
seated very well I think I think in the
end we saw some great improvements it's
uh it was really exciting actually to
see that transformation
he helped me pick out this dress today
oh so Trey like dressed you today yeah
because apparently like wearing my mom's
dresses is
apparently dressing like a 45 55 year
old woman
dating and the dating
wife School episode
thank you Trey for helping Pearl thank
you from everybody
no it was a great day it was a great day
we went through some great tips uh for
you know so I mean it's difficult for
guys but it's difficult for women as
well have got to wait for guys to
guys so it's really hard for women
okay so what can women do in order to
put themselves in the best possible
position for a guy turn to cover
my love to see dressing is one element
of that so that's true you know it was
it was very cool it's very cool
all right who do we've got somebody
straight from wrecker who's already
viral
you already went viral with pearls dude
he broke she broke she broke Twitter you
already broke Twitter
all right I am Ali I have a YouTube
channel at real time saving you guys
and you guys well yeah Pearl
single-handedly helped me to irritate
the feminist past the point of no return
to this day to this day I still
get viral clip and I give it because it
wasn't planned I wore that dress just
because I like wearing flower dresses on
top that we were just playing around in
the back of an Uber but
but my YouTube channel is
On Cue Pearl thank you Pearl appreciate
it I mean I mean you're entertaining in
town dead so it was it was a perfect
storm oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah honey just
just for the people that didn't
[Music]
and mostly submissive but it's just
learning how to cooperate with your man
I was out of pocket okay I was out of
pocket I had to learn how to let a man
lead and we've all been happier ever
since
and lastly my friend uh
my name is
Palermo
are moving down a lot of internet show
in the last couple of years especially
for young English people that might be
on me because I'm an episode with better
Squad which is a
younger black comedian YouTuber quite
popular there have been done another
show with you which is a famous football
player for uh
some TV channel
they'll be worked with a lot of the
English rapper of the new generation
like Morrison benign and fresh the kid
as an actor in their video clip
fair enough
right ladies and gents um
we are discussing whether or not men and
women
but
to start ourselves we can watch a video
first we're gonna get your views and
opinions on it
and um then we're gonna talk about it so
bless him
can we play the first video clip please
more likely to get married pursuing a
career and a family is more difficult
for women than the disc for men if
you're a woman with an IQ of 145 the
only minimum you're going to be
interested in are man with an IQ of 145
and above and that's like 1
attractive then she's going to be a very
intimidating Target and she would have
been in all likelihood are going to
approach her
point
s
more likely
I have thoughts I feel
and you guys could let me know for a
guy's point of view I don't think it's
that she's an intimidating Target I
think it's that she doesn't want
like I don't think men really care how
smart you are I think it's just like
nothing to come you know I mean they
don't want like a box of rocks but I
don't think it's like I don't think to
me I just from what I know it doesn't
seem like
seem like YouTube
I'm coming from a perfect ground so to
me I never really went to school so uh
I'm not related to any of the modern
society of PhD
it's perfectly fine you know education
is good but I speak three language I
never went to school so I'm able to
communicate with people so to me
whatever is the state is
if you treat me as a person I don't see
any problem
that's what I found like it seems like
more of the issues when girls are smart
they act like they're better than
everyone else
and like that's like when they say oh
they're intimidated by it it seems like
it's not them actually being smart it's
just them acting like they're better
than everyone else well it depends how
it manifests later right because I mean
one of the response goals I haven't
dated
a sunny
one of the smallest women overdated was
a PhD she's doing a PhD in philosophy
she's a lady in Gold also very very
attractive super super smart but she
wasn't the sort of person who was
parading it around
it's also quite sweet and she was quite
sort of
course I'm quite feminine right so I
think it depends how it manifest I think
I think what you're talking about I
think it's more
it's more what are some women get you
know like the CEO type energy well I was
just thinking what he said when he said
intimidating
intelligence I think they're more
intimidated by looks
really
um but I suppose if a woman's got the
full package that might seem he
according to
um you know according to Jonah Pearson
smart women
and their heart
but that is
what she did say it's because they're
interested in there
foreign
[Music]
what they're looking for I mean uh
from my experience especially by
compilation in the last
trial it is completely changed so if
it's warmer maybe it's not interested to
the manner's agenda because it doesn't
for the job he does or whatever us she
eases which to us to another girl
into another girl yeah
I mean I uh the last five of my
relationship three of it the guests that
left me for a woman and they all want to
come back they
won't pass it
if I wasn't go good in the first place
right at the low level life I always get
taking the Peace of myself why are you
coming back to me that's going to be an
outline I'm sure
women running around just because
it is
ago
of a sexual and to know the story
although we have a lot of jokes
there was a joke
basically they were talking about the
YouTube the two guys together because
they have relationships
oh yeah you know the
dog
friend perception
argument huh an opportunity so you might
be there the way I do sex with you no
really so in between I
know 18 years
he came up to say you know
do more
SEC and we'll decide to our world's
conversation was doing what that's
interesting point I stopped everybody
about the challenge
he got no boars
no no
no no my thing is I feel very confident
saying this I don't think it's hubris or
anything like that so I'm a high IQ
woman
instead
I was just looking around in my class
of whack I was so bored out of my skull
he ended up getting me tested they put
me into like these other classes where
you got to meet with other like higher
IQ kids during like it was one day a
week out of school and so yeah I do
think that that has impacted my dating
I think like in general and I'm not
trying to be mean at all it's just I
don't I don't be with a man that's
within me and I don't think that having
a high IQ as a man equates to having a
people I've ever met my
mother could have been Carpenter's
business
or you know I think even I would
probably quite a few fishermen out there
right right
um but I think in that circumstance you
just have to be prepared to compete and
I think it has led me to prefer nerdier
men I think that's
will change
yeah I
could front but you know resource
acquisition hypergamy well loads are
taking over the world I mean if you look
at if you look at the tech industry
the planet has become
because of them aren't nerds would you
say that nerdy guys are more lonely
oh yeah oh they are lonely I mean maybe
that's why I've been able to end up in
relationship
this has just been my
is dating more
with on both ends we've both been lonely
people because it's hard you don't meet
other people that are as smart as you
and again it's not trying to be mean
it's just like imagine trying to speak a
different language you wouldn't be able
to socialize with others around you but
again that's what I meant by I think
there's a social trade-off whereas like
you might have a guy like maybe he's not
you know with IQ points and IQ isn't
everything but he's more socially savvy
and it was like 2
2.
you know maybe they are
they are people there's that kind of
intelligence which is very
very handy sort of based on
Shiite figures and things like
things like those people I think for
some reason and I told a generalized
book can often find it quite difficult
to be social you know the the
emotionally the EQ sort of things is
sometimes a lucky little bit but then
there are also people who
sort of I mean I'm certainly not any of
those things I'm certainly not [ __ ]
with data
from that you know I I feel like I'm
slave
um so I think it depends on the way that
the
Theory
chest one is literacy
mathematics
sounds really stupid you know you can be
technically good at some things it's
true the new Society is all about
computer I think right so a male as a
male is always uh about do something
constructive in a way
I'm coming from a country which is Italy
I mean I grew up in art everywhere so
it's really building some things people
can see you're right right you're right
and and
that way they've pressed them
that it won't be possible anymore
because we see even with the new new
business people like chess piezos or
even
they're not interested to go through it
or make something outside the
speaks in that
the body will be fixed on a visual War I
won't say
anything we always
and either
because this is the reality as long as
that's a whole lot
of
interaction
control game where you cover your eyes
screen
and now it's a major thing you know
people do it is something they like it
would you rather
spend the rest of your life with someone
you don't like that much
or be lonely oh I I take the
companionship
companionship I personally is another
person because you won't like him
everything or everybody yeah but like
it's can you think of a girl you've
dated
that much like how much
so she's gonna
type
book which would you guys pick
yeah
I don't think I could do
someone that I'm not
I just I think I
think I resentful about it I'm sorry
like I think I also think that's a
problem with modern women like our
grandmothers could do it and take it to
the Grave
that's not me
like every other woman that
over the age of 35 and alone I would
just get me a group of girlfriends you
know what I mean
pretty much every day if I
if I I think I would I think I would go
with the loneliness to be honest because
I don't think it's actually loneliness
really I think I would rather not be in
a relationship with somebody that I
wasn't that into I just developed my own
interests I'd be out with friends and
stuff I mean there's you know Rolex of
us who wrote that article use kind of
the myth is
you don't have to be
like great time they're traveling
they're making friends do you know what
I mean so I would rather go if I had to
choose I'd rather go for that lifestyle
hurry up traveling meeting new people
doing
doing rather big shaped up with some of
them just for the sake of it I wasn't
that into it
man
I don't
think they're very lonely very late you
know like
a lot of
the type they're doing there
they don't have it out
an outlet they don't have a social life
literally by themselves so when you say
that I think men of men are very
difficult more difficult
because nobody has to say to you really
talk to you I'm I'm being quite an
active in all my life around
um
I've been a little bit known for a
central Tinker did which is too long to
explain now and uh but I used to be
organized party you know I used to be
made a lot of social events and then
obviously College started
appeared
and most of the people are just gone
I never hear from them back then
opposites start to make my older or
other fine tools people but I I had a
lot of friends that killed himself
that's before they call me oh really
okay and uh I was being sorry because uh
they didn't look
if you know what I mean so or at least
with me because I talked to them when I
say I talked to everybody on
you know and uh um you have to say that
it's not really normal because most of
the power time I see people I know why
you talk with the guys that you don't
say the way it is he's still a person
you don't know him that's not your
business why but that's mean it's
difficult for guys because uh we need to
look Central way you know
and especially if you let's say a
straight ordinary cloudy she doesn't
wanna you know discover different kind
of sexuality right it would be more
lonely you know but then what's
happening
at night much sex
yeah
who are virgins and I think one of the
major
I was watching this thing on school
shoes
you look at like the ammo of a school
shooter it's going to be a lonely dude
it doesn't have much of a social life
can't really interact socially um
awkward right and all of these things
are
okay and so they do
crazy random
ly
so when I was asking about like who
deals with loneliness
or better I would say
seems
I don't think
to disagree
it is more so fermented
men but women
also many more likely to own firearms
than women too
well actually a morbid fact but in this
context but no I've noticed that there's
a lot of lonely men out there these they
still manage to be gainfully employed
they
fill their day and I think like with
women if they're lonely they can't
stomach if they can't stand it they
can't cope they have to continue to Vie
for male attention or get a group of
girlfriends but I've just I've seen a
lot of you know quote-unquote lonely men
throw themselves into their work and
even if they're not
they're not show up to work every day I
don't know why but that's my perspective
on why I disagree and why I think men
can handle it more and I think it does
come to a little bit like
only
prefer that you know if
some feminine women and have a legacy
yes but you know I've I've seen men who
are by themselves and as long as you're
living you're a full life
you're too and you're doing the things
that you like set out to do
a cross-country RV and I think you'll be
okay but women I think it drives them
insane well put it this way right would
it be easier for let's say this this
hypothetical guy who's in his
going into something
to be that guy who's out there he's
doing the ultra marathons he's doing
that kind of thing is that is that
figure more conceivable than a female at
the same age
can we imagine a female at the same age
being occupying that position or do you
think that's gonna be tricky for her
women women will like self-employed I
mean they were also like explode no
they're just like gain about
foreign
women don't get a true chance to be
lonely until they're really old
true or false
from a female or my age you know they
said after 50
50
connection they ended up lonely bye guys
as you said before on the 30th I have a
lot of young young friends because of
people in my
oh anyway
so they busy they don't play and ask me
but when you were 20 30 did you have
more sex I say yeah that wasn't easy but
because there was no all the digital
cropping application you used to be
going out talking to girls meeting them
you maybe didn't even change the number
but because it used to be going Club
where you know the other be back in
maybe another week after
change the phone number they might be
and and then I will start you know now
you're on digital where uh basically a
good looking guy together he gets a
thousand
people you won't have any conversation
really
I have a question for the guys
um everyone here is over 40 right yes
I'm 51.
50 cool me out like that though so
my whole life I mean the world's been
pretty modern there's been social media
I got my first Facebook account when I
was in eighth grade
are women worse today have you noticed
that women are like substantially worse
now than when you guys were in your 20s
um would you say they're [ __ ] now
more
um like I'm just curious because a lot
of times I I think sometimes Jeff
or I wanted to know if is there action
would you say social media made women
worse I would say social media made
women worse I would say social media
foreign
and it's not really an interaction
it's like a
okay if
you know what you're like
you're like we can
do my energy we can steal each other
when working when we're face to face
people are looking on phones right now
but you don't get that so a lot of the
time when people meet up face to face in
person
but that's why that's why you should
still be approaching him face to face
yeah
like apps on the side if you want
and the reason is
you know I've been around the block and
[Music]
are you asleep
[Laughter]
no I
only remember
but I don't I think it's a bit of a myth
of Rights don't talk Spanish actually
you got these younger guys who are on
social media and they're like oh yeah
it's so difficult now it used to be as
if it used to be super easy in the past
and it never did the Dynamics the
Dynamics were always the same women
always wanted the best
guy you know it's school if you weren't
the guy who was having a football team
or whatever she wasn't gonna look at you
I mean he was always the hierarchy has
always been
so I don't think it was magically easier
before Instagram
it's still got rejected it would still
you know it still sucks all of those
things were still in play I think what
has changed and this is where you make a
good point um
the dating apps and social media have
opened have blown open
um opportunities for for women to be
a problem I don't think again that we
talk about
a lot of global dating
so whereas before you know Sandra from a
small town in the south of England
maybe the only guy she's
exposed to really
kind of area
you put some
something
um you know and then she's like well
hang on a minute do I really want to
date
so do you guys think that social media
is making harder or is it for you
personally well but but just to just
kind of
kebabs and I suppose I'm sort of arguing
to kind of two things at the same time
but I believe both
it was never like easy
opportunity
that was ever easy but
um I think that the increased
competition now has made things has made
um
and um and I think the way around that I
think the hat is to be having
conversations in real life because you
you get to
uh showcase your personality in real
life in a way yeah
so for me personally it hasn't made a
huge difference but I'm operating in a
different way because I'm traveling a
lot and I'm also I'm
what was the question yesterday
I was just curious if um the dating apps
has made it for you personally because
you have a bit of a platform of you know
girls get signed in
harder easier for
you well it's always been easy for him
don't do that
me I've been I've always been a social
person
right it's just me and
so I've always loved to interact with
people socially
of course that's because you have access
to more people but what what is those
are made you more cautious
so it's like
I don't know you interacting with you
but I actually don't know you so I've
got to be more guarded whereas if
impersonating
and you kind of feel something you can
feel something you know what I mean
social media is also
contributed to
being more
is that your false reality yes it is you
know so obviously I'm a woman right but
I'm married to a man who's Gen X so my
husband
curious I'm like was it better was it
World son he was he just basically told
me he was like no there's always been
city girls because I would ask him
because we would work out together and
obviously women are happy
always
yeah well I'm just thinking like the
girls that they complain about that are
older and acting like city girls like
before social media they were still
there oh yeah
created the divorce rate the way it the
ones that left the marriages they're
which Beach City goes oh just a bit well
I just I feel I'm a Christian I feel bad
about Saint Jose so he's like he's like
told me there's been hoes in the 80s
yeah
yeah men get exposure to like real
female nature whereas like you had to be
the guy who understood women and could
get women in order to see Justified
I feel like posting it before you had to
have games big game shout out to Gen X I
love y'all well I mean the internet has
blown open all of that stuff because
it's allowed guys to share
here but if you don't look Central Way
from internet you're not gonna get
anything no no this is the reality is it
if you look good looking
to attract somebody but I got a friend
of mine which obviously it's not a good
looking he's a guy
it doesn't meet nobody through social
dating right I go again which is a
friend of mine
of mine she got three
picked up this is the difference so
again again
about the
they don't want to meet their life but
that's the first thing
when I interact with people I need to
understand if somebody communicates for
real or he is doing for any other reason
right
um that's coming for me really so I
don't think internet make it make you
for somebody may be living in some
little village in the world give me
somebody else
so have a more opportunity for our game
now for a guy I'm talking about a guy a
man
is that point he was just gonna be
humiliated so where does this we're in
the house it has to have no Society are
the rich get rich in the poor kepora
if that's the way it is yeah
the only thing I would ask though has he
did that guy really optimize his dating
profile has he got some really good
shots and really
but then again
then again I'm in the show business okay
I'm not famous but whatever yeah uh so
it's a catfish I don't know how to look
good in a central way if I want to get a
good picture
pools you know and and that's different
but when you're gonna miss somebody
you're not representing what they see on
the picture I said thank you very much
bye yeah it's happening right so even at
the guys say it's no point to give you
the best glamor shot that you don't look
where you are because then when I'm
gonna meet you
um
and you know yeah of course there is
something
but it was always difficult but it also
like if you were if you weren't that
great looking
1992
question for Troy um my theory about
like what we can constantly complain
about my mind
and we're all about the gratification
so walk me through okay well first I
have to ask you this question in order
to ask you that
I already
yes okay just walk me walk me from start
to finish getting a woman
start to finish
the process because it's
condom too
um
do you want me to say oh I have to have
to do seven days
before I got it
right
there we're in order to get in bed I
think it was
a lot different and required that
delayed gratification which gave
foreign
within you know
swear it's there yes it was very much
like he waited
waiting for you so yes it was it was
definitely started when people use their
house films yes exactly exactly so I
think now you've got into gratification
because you're in contact with that but
you guys could be
big well-being contact with other girls
so you're you're picking
several different goals she's probably
several different guys so yeah
everybody's in this kind of like
enhanced being kind of kind of but so it
was it was in some way slower back in
the day I think because of communication
was it was it it was that was it did it
take longer to sleep with a girl back
then well no that's that's what I'm
saying
[Music]
that's before
it was literally the quoting process
which I don't think exists today in the
same way
you see back in the day I used to I used
to party
so my strategy was basically
basics
so
and sort of like
I don't think
I mean a lot of these dating stuff for
me it was taking place in sort of
nightlife you know clubs and things like
that I don't think it's necessary took a
huge amount of time more I think it was
more like her for a first day maybe not
sleepy on the first day maybe the second
day kids but it's kind of
I don't I didn't but then maybe that was
the nature of the woman that I was
meeting and the kind of situations
to just sleep around or were you trying
to get a girlfriend well I mean I I had
this long long period through my teens
of being absolutely terrible with
before any himself a bit offensive you
know so I was completely hope it's
although actually I did get some
interest from girls over I was at
college with and stuff but I was always
excited about this that person
did you ever get her no so I would you
know it would be fixating on the
get really upset about that
it was all a disaster then I hit 20 and
that my attitude sort of changed I
started to go out be a little bit more
cocky a bit more funny
um and I met the first girl and the
first girl was really really beautiful
we got together
for about six months the relationship
was a train wreck because I was
although I managed together you know to
be my girlfriend I was absolutely
terrible if women didn't know what I was
doing so she ended up dumping me about
six months later and I was completely
devastated can I ask a question but but
just yeah but after that then after
now I'm gonna go out
there I'm just gonna play the game
the game being that
so then I went more into like a cycle of
promiscuity for a long time right so you
see before
got into that cycle yeah where you were
kind of like not having
obsessed with women
stayed along that path yeah
where do you think
what type of man do you think you would
have been
because I think that the reason I took
about loneliness is like yeah with men
and women because I think a lot of
and women
seem to a path of loneliness and it just
becomes
that if you
it is a
likely that you will
you're not decided to make a change yeah
yeah
um well I was what do you think you
would have been well I I think you're
probably right and I think it would have
Builds on itself
well yeah exactly like if you look at
some of the you know the sort of the
incel kind of
groups and people that you get online
yeah perpetuating that narrative and I
think I could fall into that way of
thinking I mean I was very lucky because
firstly the internet hadn't been
impacted
that wasn't
that sort of
that was that and secondly I was lucky
just for sort of like personal my
personal stuff that happened to me
whereby I kind of just had this almost
psychic change and I I sort of
different way and when it's time to
react to be different but
now what I try to teach people to
buy dinner
because I was different because
you know have sex
Eddie was saying it's more likely to not
have sexual maybe a couple of years a
woman not having sex or a contraction
with a man is that [ __ ] most of the time
women can get sex tomorrow yes for the
most part I mean Ali that what are you
talking about there where you're saying
people not having sex for a year
less likely since then afterwards and is
that male or female or both
so it's both so when it comes to
sexlessness both men and women of
today's generation are more success than
previous generations however men are
more impacted than women but I think
that is
if I can't be
I can't be this thing
we were talking about pheromones we were
talking about pheromones earlier though
there's an interesting phenomenon which
I'm sure
you recognizing surely guys here
recognize which is that
if you've just met a girl you've just
had sex then then all of a sudden you
seem to get loads more interest from
other women
right
people investor
pictures about you yeah whoever is
surrounding of people that's why I got a
lot of
a lot of kids to have connection yeah
just to become more public but try I
don't mind taking the peace because I
say okay I'm nobody but I didn't find
them you put my enemy coming out all
right because I've got so many things
which is coming out so obviously you
sound like I'm sure enough but if
if you believe in London or nowadays
inside
the new generation is is almost bisexual
bisexual for men or women but hey I
don't know where you're living guys
are you saying that man
yeah
I do a lot of social political events I
work in the accepting
if you even sound too straight in a way
especially as a guy yeah people are
looking like oh no this guy's slightly
to us I mean there are central people
that like to see
the position of playing I mean you can
do whatever you like but it doesn't mean
it's right it might be right for you
because you like to do
but I got no problem
any religion any race in the world that
it to me never been a problem but when I
say in my opinion A lot of people
doesn't mean it's right to wrong about
just don't like it what can I do
in order to attract care
opposite they need to look good in a
central way because um and especially
nowadays looking good it doesn't mean
really
okay
so I cannot be fit like I used to be
fitted where I see them
you got self-confidence which is awesome
but but at the reality
you are what you are yeah so
you need to balance that to find
your way to do things but and and that's
the same thing for gas there is a
majority of girls they think in the very
good looking which is nothing wrong with
the confidence of it but to me the as an
ugly guy as I Define myself because I
was a man work in the fashion industry
right so I know what good looking is and
what
right they're thinking they're good
looking if you are again online and
people give you money just to see you
all the fun or even Tick Tock it doesn't
mean good looking you just call a bunch
of loser right they don't want to
interact in the society that's what the
society want they make you to do that
right so
you're working as a dating advisor I
didn't get it yeah yeah so you know I
think a change right even 2007 me in the
past it used to be get a dating so you
get the first date but even on the first
date you need to show you were
interested to the girl so you at least
have to have to try to kiss it doesn't
mean no physically you have to kiss her
but she needs to know yeah you're
interested because if she doesn't see
that it's finished no I agree the second
time you got to go for it because uh
it's not my surgery because you won't
have a third time unless did you get
consent first of course you always have
questions how is that concerned somehow
I never use drugs or alcohol
relationship you know I'm quite clear
but unless she's really interested you
won't have a third time well no you're
right you've got to show your interview
yeah you've got to show your return up
front for sure but that thing about
there's something about if you're if
you're a guy and you've recently been
sexually successful it seems like women
can sense that on you somehow yeah oh
yeah and then they and then positive why
but yeah yeah yeah and then you're more
likely to be selected again so it kind
of Builds on itself doesn't it men with
limited options they worship you they
kiss the ground that you walk on and
it's very off-putting yeah or they they
just treat you like you're like God and
you can do no wrong it's like it's like
you'll be kind of an [ __ ] and be like
okay you're beautiful anyway you're like
what so are you saying that you guys
would like piss man off on purpose just
to see no absolutely absolutely I mean
it's it's like conscious I just think
like when we do [ __ ] tests we're women I
could just see all the black pill guys
like oh my God no I can explain it right
because it sounds bad which honestly you
know just be happy that there's like
women that are being honest um now I
don't think that it's a always like
conscious like I found myself in my
marriage the only time that I do it and
it's very few and far between it's like
I I'll ask my my husband for something
I'm like it's a 50 50 shot he's gonna
get it for me I'm like can you give me a
glass of water knowing I have two feet
you know what I mean and he'll look at
me he'd be like what are you doing I'm
like oh just kidding I'll just get my
own glass of water
um but otherwise you've got it though
now what but I think it's on the hand I
don't I don't know my I think my husband
is just very much like you know I'm
pregnant right now so if I was like nine
months pregnant I think he would do it
for me but I think that man looks at me
and he's like you're not really tired
like you're messing with me go and get
that glass of water yourself but in
terms of uh like I think why women do it
is because if you can fold to me the
woman in your life who you need to
protect then you can fold to the world
and I need a man that's going to be able
to protect me so I think that's a little
bit why women will do things like that
but the glass of water thing is just
something that like we got we got back
we got back up on that and get it we
gotta flesh that out so you're saying
that if you think that your man will
fold to you yes that he will be like
basically soft when he's out in the
world yes and then it's probably going
to be a risk so you don't want him to
fold to you now
essentially no
no text right so you know
um look at my first trimester and
wrapping it up and you know I've been
very tired and exhausted and so my
husband will go and he'll make a meal
for me or he'll like get a meal for me
and things like that it's very
contextual but no I I don't want a yes
man and a lot of women have had
experiences with Yes Man I mean we know
that women have leverage I'm sure
Pearl's had experiences with yes men too
it's not fun it's not cute and you know
that's the thing it's like it's very
interesting for men because if we ask
for something or if we say something we
actually mean it you know I mean like
generally men will be like okay this
this and that's what I want but women be
like this this this is he gonna do it
yeah
I mean like we don't actually it's
partially like unconscious I'm just
smart enough and aware enough to tell
when I'm doing it I was just thinking
though I can imagine all the all the
haters in the chat be like sort of like
oh my God like like it's it's women
actually sitting and complaining about
guys doing things that are nice for them
oh my God like he was too nice oh he
bought me this glass of water can a girl
be too nice to you yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I think they can because it's like
what we were saying earlier I think I
think actually
um if a girl is too into you and she
does too much for you I think that can
be a little bit jarring as well I think
actually the genders have probably
actually not that dissimilar in it I
think there's female stems but that's
just because you're overshooting your
shot like you need to take a Donna Peg
you need to you know I think I think
it's cosmetic I think a lot of the time
men are not used to
they're not used to having women like
really like a lot of men are not used to
having women like really loving them I
think that might you know what I mean
yeah I think that's what it is it's like
because we're used to kind of doing the
pursuing and doing all the kind of all
this kind of stuff like when a woman
says oh my God you're amazing oh my God
I can't get enough you're like is this
woman like is she is she lying like can
I have an example where a girl did too
much
well I was I mean I was dating a girl a
while back and it was just like and was
it her looks was she no no no she was
really she was she was very cute
um and but she was just it felt like she
couldn't do enough I mean she'd always
make me breakfast in the morning and she
and then she'd make me and I don't even
eat breakfast so that was kind of
annoying I'm like listen I don't really
eat breakfast I like to just have a
coffee and then she comes oh and she
bring this you know the porridge and
it's piled up with fruits then she's
like oh can I get you something else can
I get you can I use some eggs can I use
some eggs right no no no you know it's
too much too much and I mean again you
know was it too much too soon though
how young you were not not really I mean
we've been dating for for a while it
just I think I think maybe it's partly
personal to me because I think there's
an element of me I'm quite independent
independent being like too closeted by
people it makes me feel a bit so that
might just be a personal preference to
me I think you're right what what um
what culture was she from was she
Western was she Eastern European she was
actually she was actually Eastern
European oh okay because I feel like
that's uncommon for those women that's
the way they act though I mean uh
um I'm from Rome but even in Rome
because in my generation
uh I guess got to be virgin at least
back in the days for the marriage
on my first 15 years old I understand if
I wanna hook with the girl on my age is
basically impossible and obviously
living a room is full of tourists and uh
but the first relation I had with
tourist care which at the time they have
slightly longer early day but we're
talking about in a week and 15 days I
have to find a new a new partner or my
teenager right that's why I start to
learning the language I used to be
taking the piece about it because I
speak Italian English Italian French
Italian Spanish right and that's why so
but even when I came to London one thing
can understand forget about the London
again because they're too busy they got
the standard so they want to interact
with you because the moment the CEO is
Italian is like that they don't even
know you so again I started to went with
people living in London like me so a lot
of East European a lot of Italian
American as well a lot of Latin American
and and that's the way it is
um and the more uh let's say
accommodating in a relationship they got
some kind of I don't want to say
servitude but they do the kind more of
open-minded in central Kings yeah
obviously if they become too sweet you
start to think oh well maybe they want
to get married and and that's for a lot
of guys do you not want to get married
I'm 51. I I've been living a few girl
for some time but not for for long I
mean the longest relationship I have was
three years really right and uh I I just
do things the No Ordinary for people do
you think that's part of the loneliness
though because people don't want to get
married now it's not why I don't want to
get married it's just uh I'm doing
different things I'm gonna do a nine to
five job uh I'm not a financial violence
or I'm working as a postman uh I do
freelance job through security show
business then as I say to you I've been
very sick I tried to talk so I'm not
getting stressed in a relationship if
the same department is not On My Level
or she doesn't understand that my dear
you know you want to live your life from
it's okay go you know I was going to
read super yeah go and go for it okay
guys thank you so much for these super
chats I'm gonna read a couple
um actually I'm gonna read all of them
hold on okay 90 free-toe pet um the
difference in checking is men aren't
abusive with it um stop and think
it's complicated says women make it hard
for men to have sex with them Pearl
quotes one out of three men in one out
of three men haven't had sex in the past
year and most men are virgins before 30.
I didn't say most if you're gonna quote
me
one out of three um with this
information in mind do you think most
boys and men develop corn addictions if
sex is hard to get think about this
Dustin Denton um 500 Super Chat
lonely lonely lonely makes matchmakers
rich 8K for 24 matches or I'm on a
second company now for 5K 90 free-toe
pet in the past we had shame now only
the oppressors are ashamed that's the
real issue men live in logic and Truth
we can't help and but call out female
lies
um
I'm morphess um audio has no bass and
the volume is low
um Seth blader I agree that women only
get a chance to experience loneliness or
I agree that women don't get a chance to
experience loneliness until they're much
older they appear to only experience it
when their long-term partner dies or
their vast their last friend dies
a Kenmore it's not loneliness but lack
of purpose for men most men conflate
having a woman as a sense of purpose
Captain Cisco pearly have you heard of
the legendary YouTuber name from South
North Carolina Edward Anderson actually
haven't heard of him
um Terrell Clark her intelligence
doesn't affect my income um thank you
I'm Kirsten Eskimo
um
yeah that's all of them go ahead Sarah
if you have another video you wanted to
show yeah I have another video
um
thank you blessing and we can play the
other video if possible
is there really something wrong with the
audio today I don't know there might be
but but like just so she could hear it
fine in her rooms right I don't there's
enough comments yeah yeah but I think
worst case we'll just edit it and post
oh it's good now okay
let's see oh there's this magic from the
beginning
I'm getting pregnant welcome to 2022
where you can do anything a man can do
I'm so excited to finally be here you
are going to love it feminism has done
so much for women do tell no more aprons
first of all oh do we finally have a
butler to cook for us oh gosh no you'll
just eat pre-made greasy crap out of a
bag on your way to and from work I
suppose that sounds convenient so I get
to work outside the home totally you get
to sit in a cubicle all day while you
stare at a computer screen chugging
coffee so liberating right I suppose I'm
at work all day but we finally have a
Rosie the robot made
no you'll still have to do all the
cleaning what your weekends are for
cleaning and laundry oh and errands and
yard work weight so I have to work full
time plus still manage my home full-time
I mean you want to have it all right
okay but what about my husband is he
amazing what no you're not married you
live in love with your cat what you do
date though a lot you can just have sex
with whoever whenever you want that
sounds kind of gross actually just pick
them off of this app what about
pregnancy oh there's this magic pill you
take totally wrecks your hormones but
keeps you from getting pregnant so you
can you know knock some boots the pill
is Magic well it's mostly effective but
don't worry if by chance you do get
pregnant you can totally just kill the
baby by having an abortion why would I
do that so you can get back to work duh
someone has to fill that cubicle space
okay am I at least happy uh uh I mean
yeah as long as you don't skip your
antidepressant pill another magic pill
gotta cope somehow I think I'll just
stay here
get to have purple hair
anything a man can do yes
thoughts ladies and gentlemen I love
that video that woman is speaking my
truth she's speaking my Truth for those
of you that that don't know she's on
Instagram actually and she does these
cute skits so go and look for her and
find her because she hasn't been like
discovered she went viral and then Tick
Tock took her account but I think that
what she's saying is absolutely true my
goodness heck yeah I'd rather be home I
was in the Army like that that job beat
the femininity into me I'm good I'll
stay home so do you think do you think
feminism is one of the reasons for
female loneliness
well well yes I mean are you for real so
so like let me get this straight like
you know alternate reality I'm a liberal
woman
um okay so I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
frumpy I'm gonna put my career first I'm
allowed to be fat I can have colored
hair and I can think that men are my
oppressor and then naturally they're
gonna want to marry me and talk to me
and have conversations with me
absolutely not yeah yes women lonely yes
and they need you to be in the tribe and
if you go against feminism as a woman he
will be lonely I mean Pearl and I have
had this experience we go against The
Sisterhood we ain't got that many
girlfriends that's why you always see us
together we ain't got nobody else you
know I have so many friends
yeah
you pissed off the whole madness here
right back you ain't got nothing you're
talking about they love me they love me
pearly things numbered eight and it was
something just probably think seven what
can I can I say something because female
loneliness looks like this right this is
what it looks like and I've seen this a
lot nowadays so I'm going to read from
wired.co.uk and it says the Leo sorry
lello a luxury Swedish sex toy brand oh
gosh says that it has sales increased by
40 and Summers a sex toy and lingerie
retailer has had a 27 increase in the
sales of sex toys compared to this time
last year
I have seen on so many different social
medias women saying oh my God my new sex
toy is amazing oh my god look how great
it is very common it's very common I
mean uh uh I don't know the number but I
think we're talking about at least 200
000 vibrator from Mountain United
Kingdom right if it's not for weak so
you need to to check that right even
last time I was with a girl on a sexy
shop and we killed it because there was
this girl was buying three four
vibrators
which one was better for the batteries
yeah and
the story I set the point to say can we
just pay for the laundry and we're going
because otherwise we're gonna stay here
forever to hear the conversation or
somebody want to buy a vibrato again the
entire people to do what they like but
if there is no interaction is a sexy
become more about watching uh yourself
or watch your porn movie which as I say
I've been on a meeting with a with an
American psychologist in a convention in
the uni it's a the difficult events for
guys is now they they maybe they have
erection but they don't ejaculating
because they they used to masturbate
themselves instead of having sex so for
them it's difficult to have like a
normal uh let's call penetration within
the other partner because they don't
feel it anymore
well I worked at a couple store for a
year which I mean that's just like PC
speak for being you know I worked at a
sex shop
um there was yeah there was a lot I
didn't know and I got offered a big
commission so I don't quite a bit on the
topic but I don't think you finished
what you were gonna say at the beginning
um yeah well with the actual article
I'll say I think you're
Eureka statement about like are women
replaced
places so basically uh men are women
yeah that's basically what it is our
women replacing memory toys but equally
sorry
but equally you know we hear all this
stuff about sex dolls now don't we the
guys are doing yeah yeah I'm talking
about those too so I
are we all just going to end up getting
jiggy with bits of plastic and ignoring
you this is okay
unpopular opinion go on
I think the world needs hookers
now look here I wouldn't want anyone I
love to do it I wouldn't want anyone I
know to do it but it is the world's
oldest profession
and and someone's got to do it
actually it's funny you say that so in
in couple stores this happened this I
guess in the 70s this is what I learned
from my my Gen X manager at the store uh
there were actual ads for local working
girls that would be in the back at local
local sex shops someone's got to do it
yeah it's illegal if we're having sex
dolls have you have you ever went to
Berlin yes right and badly there is this
club called the heaven which is a
broader basically with included with uh
two glass of uh drink a drink or
whatever
you got you got a [ __ ] hey
they it costs about 20 Euro
so
but then this kind of
this is kind of like it honestly I don't
like about it is the oldest profession
in the world like you say it's always
going to be there and then again in
London there is a very high percentage
or youngest from everywhere do
prostitution uh the down survey in the
University they say at least once the 17
to the female in the uni are done
escorting job
so that's the reality of it yeah also
that company just makes really great
toys like in general like the
engineering is just like off the wall oh
my goodness but um
yeah they teach you a lot about
engineering no it's really interesting
because they have to get down to the
female orgasm and they have to engineer
that so I just think it's like a
fascinating like I don't know but must
have a good research uh uh well they
make you go through training it's weird
yeah so wow okay so the female orgasm is
uh for women to get to that point now a
lot of them are using toys to do that so
that means that does it does that mean
that men are going to become obsolete
um I think that like I think men have a
total misunderstanding of toys and this
is my perspective
um so like there are some women that I
think
are replacing men with toys but I think
those kind of women you just see them be
very sex positive and single on social
media and you're like come on girl like
at some point you're gonna want a
boyfriend right but no matter what kind
of toy you get it's still it's not gonna
replace you know the weight of a man the
breath of a man feeling his skin on your
skin so it only it only goes so far
right but I think also people forget
this you know statistically uh a lot of
women aren't climaxing so like it might
not it's not just yes yes and so uh some
women are in relationships and they're
getting these toys to make sure that
they can get there in the bedroom with
their partner but then isn't it better
than for men and women to have these
conversations as to how to give a woman
an orgasm wouldn't that be better than
to just be like getting a toy well I
mean I don't it depends because every
woman's anatomically different too like
I mean we'll get in the weeds with that
but I won't get too too far into it but
what I will say is that I do think that
there is a social phenomenon of female
worship like self-worship you know like
like sex isn't even about being it being
between a man and woman I'm doing this
for myself I'm an independent woman I
can you know get myself off and I think
that that's like disgusting and not at
all romantic so that I think is true but
you know are women replacing mammoth
toys I mean I think it's possible but
the only woman that I thought the only
woman that I saw in the store over the
year working there where I was like very
sure that I think this woman is
replacing them with toys they're like
the most ugly women I've ever seen in my
life I was like nobody's trying to tap
that I'm sorry all right redhead from P
feminist no just well no like you know
like 300 pounds you know just like on
Camp probably meth heads I don't even
know alcoholics it was bad but it's it's
hard to say I mean the the the sale of
the of the toys may have have gone up
exponentially but who who's like like
you say who's actually like it because I
mean I walked through Soho before and
there's quite a few adverts up for um
outside a couple of sex shops I think
probably because of because Halloween
was just just was uh just gone and um
it's they seem to be targeted at couples
actually it seems to be sort of like oh
you know she can dress up in this cute
outfit for him and you can use this toy
and it seems to be more like that and
actually when I've been into those
stores with girls because I've done that
sometimes you know we go on a date be
like oh let's have a look in here haha
you know it's a bit sexy sort of thing
um you'll often see couples in there
actually more than I mean this is purely
anecdotal so I don't know but but I do
wonder I think it's is it because
Society is becoming more more sexualized
sexualized more sex positive and so
these things can be introduced into the
into the bedroom as part of a
relationship as opposed to these women
just going off on their own and you know
yeah and women can overuse the toys as
well so that could present a problem so
if you're talking about like women
replace a woman who's replacing a man
yeah you yeah you're gonna know because
you're not gonna be able to do anything
because she didn't like fried her Bean
off she didn't fried it off is that the
technical term
as well yeah doctor I've got a problem
you fried your beans
I'm sorry to say Miss Drummond you fried
your Beetle
did you see the news come out a few days
ago when Pope Francis say even London
priest was born you know and that's why
I don't [ __ ] with Catholics
that's really funny to me no I swear to
God this is why this is a group of
people that have no home when it comes
to religion because I grew up 12 years
Catholic school and now these Popes are
wild and now what on Earth why is he
saying that uh because it's a fact you
know the geodesic
Pope Francis you can find the BBC News
it's a basically uh he complained about
that there are too many Temptation even
for priests and none because it's been
find out that what's important right so
we're talking about news come out three
days ago I'm coming from an old Catholic
Family my my family you know I go even a
bishop in my family my grandma was
hoping I become a priest because I'm
coming from an old old family and the
third son in a in a family supposedly
become a priest right but it didn't
happen obviously so but it's
understanding now the facility to have
with internet I mean when we were kids
maybe probably the older in here you
exactly if you can see a picture of a
girl naked in somewhere then nowadays
you can see a full porn movie on your
mobile whatever your age is so again
sexuality is the problem because you
know interact with people right even
when you go a partner you don't know
what are the trigger points now you need
to understand you know that Dynamic how
they enjoy you know sexuality together
it's not always the same you know that's
why when I start to talk to the man
they're looking at me like the pizza
because nobody asked a question normally
when they go in the bed they go but I
need to know you know I start to having
sex when I was 13. right wow yeah 13 19
17 I didn't get it he's Italian Guys
okay he's Italian yeah but it wasn't the
common it wasn't the common at the time
again born in 1971 right so it was
difficult to interact with guests as I
say to you I am clearly not for you at
13.
again because I start to interact we
guessed the weren't Italian so the
worker may become an iterative study so
they believe in that so they have a
really friend they didn't have any issue
with the family but I always been
careful so I never make anyone pregnant
in my life right I always been like I
grew up with really with the tradition
if you go if you got sex and then you
have a child you pray for it you know
you don't you you have no children you
have no kids I got no kids man every
shot got to be account that's my
granddad was a cop as well so as I say
very straight old fashioned and no one
in my family I got over a hundred
thousand at kids outside relationship no
one wow I know it's very unusual so when
I talk to people say I got kids that I
call it there
I mean did the teach show even if they
didn't teach you right you got more
information now the way we used to be
have when we were teenager right I think
pornography is a big issue in a way not
not because it's not supposed to be be
there because it will be there but
people got too much force informational
sexes in reality uh and if you speak
with people in the in the porn sector
they tell you well
they go fake situation for close up and
nowadays probably is easier to do a porn
movie because it's in digital so you can
roll in Non-Stop back in the days they
used to be shot in film right and film
costs money and thinking about moving a
big camera around to changing scene
especially with the poor actor did they
use Viagra and you have to stay up is an
issue so you have to be quick about it
so it's a real skill set it's a real
skills
called that hardcore movie because it
was the heart to me we have a we have a
we have a colleague actually sterling
sterling Cooper he was a a a an adult
entertainment actor and he talks about
this but that is the key thing for the
male porn star to be able to you know
before but now this is Viagra you go on
and that's season so I have a question
when in your life have you felt the most
lonely and were you in a relationship
most of the time at the end of the
relationship really because he Fade Out
really you know yeah I had I had a
long-term relationship that was five
years long
um and I felt like I was pretty lonely
in that relationship but it's because
you wake up every day knowing that
you're incompatible with someone so I
think like that in itself can be its own
psychological torture and I think that
has something to do with a reason why a
lot of marriages you know like fail or
are sexless and like guys are just at
times just going to church to stay
married just so they don't leave their
wife or cheat on their wife so yeah the
loneliest I felt was outside of was
outside the relationship but that's
because I built my relationship like
with my son and all that kind of stuff
so when I broke when I wrote that off I
was like damn yeah I think a really
important thing here for guys because
because again you know the the sort of
maybe the expected answer is like oh I
was really lonely I was in this
particular relationship and I was really
lonely because but but actually that
wasn't the case for me most of the time
I've been in relationships you know I'm
not not loneliest hasn't been my main
issue my most lonely was probably when I
was about 18 19 first went to University
really really hard to say it didn't
really socialize found it really hard to
make friends had had a few friends
didn't have girlfriend and I was I felt
really really away from family felt
really really alone and and that was a
really difficult time for me
um and then then I I got a girlfriend
and then after that I broke up with her
and then I was back into the abyss and
feeling really really lonely then again
but I think a key a key Point here is
yes the relationships with the women but
the key thing for guys really is
relationships is is friendships with
other men having a group of friends
around you because because I've never
like and now I'm in a very fortunate
Edition because I've got friends I've
got people I've known for many many
years and you know I had a breakup a
year or so ago which was which was
really tough but I've never felt that
degree of loneliness because I've always
known those people were there and I
think that's the key but you know what's
happening to men nowadays I can feel
when it comes to know this is it a lot
of them are getting into like gaming
and so all they're doing they're
interacting on their headphones on their
headsets with people and these are their
quote-unquote Bros yeah yeah
sorry sorry does hookup culture leave
people lonely of course it does
of course I I I think hook up culture
leaves you wanting
to keep if you what if you keep wanting
to do it again I've had sex with this
person I want to have sex with that
person I want to ask why is is there a
hole somewhere in you that needs that
needs to be filled so like I get it we
live in the time of hookup culture I get
it I just think um the interactions
between men and women now in these days
and times I I just don't think we're
being honest with ourselves although
although you're saying that but but I
mean I've read statistics that that
would indicate that there is hip-hop
culture going on there but it it's for
the it's rather for us to like fear yeah
there's a lot of guys there's a lot of
dudes who aren't benefiting from that
hookup culture at all you know yeah yeah
but for for women
um that's the new rate of Passage yeah
yeah becoming like going from a girl and
becoming a woman there's like that whole
phase that's in between and sometimes it
follows you like all the way into
Womanhood of course but I think that's
like really sad and truly a detriment
and there's other Rites of Passage that
women could have had that I think would
would have left them less lonely you
know things like you know having a sweet
16 uh having
um an engagement shower a bridal shower
having a wedding and things like that
but now it's like you know why don't you
just explore this new power and ability
to swipe on your phone I I just don't
think that it makes any kind of sense
yes I'll say I'll say one thing that I
think I think has changed in my
observation from back in the day and it
seems it seems like there's this sort of
default thing now for women and maybe
for men as well but for women of just
it's like being hot is the only
and I don't I don't think that was the
case years ago back in the 90s I mean I
don't know whether you can attest to
this but um it seemed it seemed like you
know there were some girls who were oh
she's she's more of a bookish kind of
intellectual or there's another one and
she wants to do it yeah be an artist and
now it seems like and I'm not saying for
everybody because obviously you can't
generalize but it does seem like the
currency now is she you know am I hot
how many followers have I got on
Instagram it's that seems to be the main
thing it's like a man it's like a
factory yeah yeah just building these
things off of factories is that
mannequins yeah and so many girls as
well develop that same sort of look uh
you know the botox you know the lips
with the filler they're just just that
same kind of look so sad because some
are so pretty before it yeah and they
like ruined their natural beauty yeah
well if I can give you an example for
example now back in the day is a girl
when she got like uh finished the
College of God deguria the university
they used to be asked for a car now they
have to have you know the boobs done
maybe yeah some you know the nose down
if it's not it's not good right is again
in a world where everything is based on
a picture yeah yes if you don't look
good in the picture you know you won't
get anything right and that's most of
the time
um and this is the reality I mean back
in the days uh personality is important
there is a minority of people like you
know to chat especially in their field
you know I grew up with painters when I
was a teenager in Rome was Arnold all
about the contemporary artists so even
if I didn't want in any College of Art
if I talk with somebody in this sector
um I kind of have a conversation and
kind of attract them on the point of
view but then again if they're very
young in a way they got Central Standard
to say oh yeah but I got to be look like
that no because they still influenced
about you know the application that's
their culture that's the way they grow
up well it's automatic like we're kind
of preyed upon so this is the crazy
thing I did a video on this once about
how like social media Engineers you as
women to it can engineer you into an
eating disorder like this is this is
actually like tested by Facebook they
did private research thanks guys thanks
for not making that public research at
the time but um okay so from my
experience and then and then I'll bring
in like the the psychological
programming so I signed up for Instagram
I didn't have an Instagram for a very
long time I think I signed up sometime
in my early 20s and all I put was like
my age so early 20s I'm a female and
then I guess it knew that I was in the
United States as well immediately my
entire full page is full of like these
fitness models and by the way like the
science doesn't even match that because
a lot of these fitness models don't have
enough fat on their body to conceive
life okay so it's like it's a subjective
definition of Health but um so like when
it came to like teen girls and that was
specifically who Facebook studied uh
that you they would just like get
flooded with you these images and you uh
everyone kind of responds to extreme
content like what's going to get you to
click and so you can go from a salad
into learning how to starve yourself as
a woman so our phones like make us hate
our bodies and that's like something
that I've gone through multiple times
um I guess with like I don't know by
bias for Via dysmorphia
um with my husband I've had these
conversations because I I was overweight
almost obese I lost 45 pounds but your
body just yeah yeah you don't look like
you're obese your girl can eat all right
you know give us
yeah well almost almost it was my BMI
was 29.9 so I lost uh 45 pounds and my
body changed a lot and then I kept
working out I actually like ran my
breasts off it's like these things are
just very stressful and they weigh in on
a woman and that's why women hi you need
to be in a relationship with a man so
that way when your body changes not
because you decided to be lizzo about it
but when your body changes he can look
at you and say like no no you're still
beautiful like yeah you ran your breast
all off like that's fine you're still
high you still got the Buns you look
good right
I think we really need that
reinforcement from men but not like just
any guy out there it's better to have
that reinforcement in a in a long-term
committed relationship because you're
gonna get insecure as a woman it's gonna
happen yeah that's very true
what a show
um we are I'm very um cognizant that Ali
is pregnant oh thank you and you're
probably tired yes I like napping yeah
you like napping
um so before we get gone Pearl do you
want to read this before we go I'll read
the rest
um all right 90 free-toe pet yes guys
buy a doll but who gets
yes guys buy a doll but who gets a pass
though dummy
um tum box great panel in discussion
some of us needed a break from the brain
dead um succumbs
um Amar Retta Ibrahim um this is amazing
the beautiful Ally and pearl
um gentle Francis Troy love you all
unfortunately Muslim girls are now
swallowing the poison of feminist ideas
um Seth blader didn't like hearing that
back I sounded like a d-bag my bad 90
free Tope the difference in checking is
men aren't abusive with it oh that was
all of them I think let me just refresh
it to make sure I didn't miss any but I
think I got them all okay cool well then
I guess we're good we're good we'll do
final thoughts before we
before we exit um go on we'll start with
you try again
all right well back in my day
um I mean look I think has technology
made us atomized and ultimately lonelier
yes probably
um I I think it's I think I think that's
undeniable is it possible though to step
outside the Matrix as as people like to
say uh these days uh yes I think it is I
don't think that you have to conduct
your entire life on through a screen I
really don't I mean I I I'm on I'm
online a lot you know I use all the
social media platforms and stuff but you
know I I also go out and meet people in
real life you you can absolutely do it
you know guys and girls and I think I
think you've got to resist this sort of
hive my mentality of everything's got to
be mediated through an app and through a
small piece of you know glass chrome and
plastic it's just not you know that's
that's not the reality we can still we
can resist we can resist the tech Giants
chains and we can go out there resist
this resist the slave mind exactly
exactly exactly and you can go out there
and just have conversations with people
it's a beautiful world there's
you know billions of people out there to
to go and talk to and have you know have
intimate relationships with if you so
wish so go and do it you know it's it's
brilliant uh guys you can find me uh my
YouTube channel is at real Troy Francis
my Twitter is at realtro Francis my
Instagram is at real Troy Francis uh so
are you are you the real trey Francis
um no just just
I am the real real real live and direct
Troy Francis yes so thanks Pearl for
having me on it's been a pleasure yeah
and women can get dating advice too now
you can absolutely absolutely women if
you want dating advice how to get that
top tier guy hit me up yeah the five
that watch the show
oh my God
thoughts on loneliness yeah I think
we're lonelier I don't think it's gonna
stop anytime soon and I think we're on
the cusp of something big when it comes
to Ai and also being able to I think
what do they call that VR virtual
reality yeah
the metaverse salt your soul there's
people getting married on the metaverse
I'm like come on y'all
um look you're not gonna be able to get
around it and I think the world wants
you to be lonely because if you're if
you're lonely you'll be you know
dependent on something bigger like a
state or a government and so it would be
incumbent upon you to build
interpersonal relationships with others
and I think it's it's really challenging
you know I don't always have fun you
know putting myself out there and taking
a risk on a friendship whether that be
like a female friendship or a male
romantic relationship but you know you
never know if you never try and I think
that the best Roi for men and women I
know that the laws are bad but I don't
want you to marry a vindictive piece of
trash of a woman but I think the best
Roi is a masculine man and a feminine
Woman Within the context of a marriage
where you you can have a witness to your
life to just have somebody who says you
know I I see you I love you and you know
I love being with you it's hard to
accomplish don't get me wrong but I I
talked to too many married couples to
think that it's impossible I know women
who are crazy and still want to like
crazy about their husbands and still
want to jump on them and pounce on him
when he comes through the door and these
these women have multiple children and I
also I've talked to high value husbands
at airports who just like can't wait to
get home and put it on their wives so I
think you know you either you think or
you swim you gotta try I'd rather die
trying than not that's my perspective if
you want to follow me I am on YouTube at
real film Sapien and on Instagram I'm at
Real Fem Sapien there as well so yeah
thank you guys for having me on it was
so fun meeting you Sarah yeah it's first
time fun meeting you too congratulations
on your pregnancy as well oh thank you
congratulations
um what can I say
the population getting older especially
in Western Europe right so there are
less and less young people so
immigration it would be try to improve
the salary situation one one thing has
to say the metaverse they destroy the
interaction with people uh a new
generation it won't be able to
conversate really face to face because
they're not used to right they're free
to do whatever they want in their own
you know social they can say and write
whatever but if you meet them face to
face and you say some things they don't
like they will react in a way tell you
you might be racist you may be
misogynist you may be you know uh
feminazi in another way so uh we need to
try to really talk to each other I mean
I I still try to organize you know meet
up with people I go to a lot of Meetup
around London where I meet people of
every kind agency especially young
people they're not used to no they know
used to be because they live in on on
social dating or social website anyway
if you want to follow me my name is Joe
Palermo my name is on the hat right the
other side right you can find me and you
can see the work I do it's quite
different don't get scared because I go
a very particular history thank you for
having me and have a good night
cool um well thank you for coming
um
and go and follow me on all my social
medias Sarah Garvey on YouTube Sarah
Garvey everywhere or the black opinion
on Instagram
and if you haven't
subscribed tell them
and you've watched two or more of our
videos tell them then we have beef what
do we have Pearl beef exactly that's me
go on Pearl okay guys a couple
announcements before we end up the end
of the show um the first being remember
we have four membership tiers the first
you get to be a part of our live chat
second Discord and behind the scenes
scenes Vlogs third you connect with me
on social media this means having access
to my inbox fourth you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month um some people
have this you know they just have random
questions they wanna know about the show
whatever the second
um is you can consult with me on social
media I've helped a lot of people with
social media
um I'm pretty good at it I think a
little bit a little bit I'm pretty good
so if you have any questions feel free
to book a call um also follow my
Instagram just dot pearly things you
have to type out the whole thing because
I am Shadow banned on Instagram and
justperly things dot five and six on
Tick Tock
um DM me if you want to come on the show
this week we're low on guests so if yeah
if you want to come on this week yeah me
cool like the video on your way out and
we will talk to you next time